all right for people who are joining
this livestream it's a bit early in the
morning and I'm not in my happiest state
here we are looking at various features
of often language which have been tagged
as experimental which we are considering
making unexperienced area is oh boy the
cloud we got a lot of things here which
we're not proposing to make an
experimental cloud rendering method that
is the question of how is jana i assume
is here right yeah I'm here
that is the question of how a particular
cell is what what method it's rendered
by and isn't that changing completely
because we've got a bunch of more native
rendering and Leon in web browsers now
um it's not it's not changing completely
I mean the two ways we have this
basically as interact boxes which means
to use the interactive JavaScript based
rendering versus a bitmap that's
produced on the server and where of
course that the client-side rendering
gets more powerful as we improve it so
the heuristic to decide which method to
use will certainly change over time but
uh no fundamentally it that that's the
option that we have okay yeah all right
well that's that I mean fine week I
guess we can leave that as experimental
I don't think it really matters that
much because it's not something we build
a lot of other stuff on I mean what when
do you set cloud rendering method um is
a misnomer
it's a so option yeah I think you could
also set it on the notebook level but
fundamentally it's a sell option and you
said it either in the graphical user
interface you know when you interact
with the cloud notebook when you just
evaluated something and you got back a
bitmap for instance then you can choose
to render it as interactive instead
really
how do you do that when I live on the
edge it comes up as a little info icon
on the right
oh that it had to win itself exactly
yeah and then I say okay fine and so
then this is the underlying option that
gets set exactly I know that's one way
yeah
you know before of course if you know if
you can employ something and you know
that it's gonna produce this warning
then you might set it in advance but
it's really something about a low level
I don't understand what okay okay next
I'm looking at the next items generate
secure authentication key and Friends
okay what aspect of this is still
experimental I mean we don't have oath
to do we have your Eric here what's the
status of these things 400 off to
somebody speak to that please
we don't have Eric here
okay well somebody who wanna hear okay
so why are we proposing to leave these
as experimental what's experimental
about them how do they relate to OAuth 2
[Music]
somebody answer this please I see Dorian
unmute himself yes that's really not
related sorry okay okay do we have like
Yan was there but I I see he isn't there
I mean accomplis will loop back to this
in five minutes okay come on Eric Shu
and I want whoever else is relevant to
this this I I think it's mostly Eric
right
um sure I'll get Eric to thank you all
right next item gallery view
Ricardo Ricardo think every okay not so
rate when we use gallery view I mean
this is something that we also want
people that the in the function
repository there's a thing for making
shingle pages right shingle summary
pages there's also the question of how
index dot HTML gets made in a directory
of cloud notebooks is that right Ricardo
can you speak to this please
I don't know about directory maybe young
can comment for that how to make index
for notebooks here the problem of
gallery view why it's experimental
because there is a second are word that
we never designed and it's the
pagination argument so right now it's
like it was a function it takes because
because what you want to do is that
right now if you provide like a thousand
elements it's deployed in a single
object going and smooth even if you need
to read only one page it paginates right
has option pagination correct but still
if you have a thousand element if you
steal the bride doesn't element letting
sorry I don't know how much talking
about its its deploying as many pages
right given but given a pagination
and so at least for the implementation
that we have now you just by a thousand
element and then you you fetch the right
page and the idea was to have something
like a function on the first argument it
takes the page number of something and
we and you can generate I remember this
you can dynamically generate the right
thing at runtime it will run but whereas
this is being done at publishing time
right this whole thing is being created
a publishing time correction right but
how would we cache it if the thing and
when we're leading people into something
where we can't really
properly because we won't get something
that has a cached HTML page if the thing
is dynamically generated at all levels
right well not really because we already
have an option to http response - to
allow that so the reason Mackin is for
caching the first time you visit the
page with the correct query string we
should be able to get okay but listen
listen listen this is not okay the whole
span of this design is not done right
because remember and so some reason this
dropped off the cloud meeting agenda
Matt maybe you can speak to this the
question of what index dot HTML does
making sense for it for a directory of
cloud notebooks yeah is whether you
expose a shingle page an index page or
whether you don't whether you have to
know the specific page in order to go
there I'm making sense yeah
and this now I think we've had some
other
I mean basically we would like to be
able to use gallery view for the front
of a resource of a repository just
directly am I making sense
right do I need to Kayla yeah you know
what you would have a bunch of cloud of
reference within you so for example if I
go to jail andum
you know repository here's one that
doesn't exist yet right I go to this
repository right I mean this is this is
a page right and we should be able to
automatically generate a page like this
from you know directories or something
else right so right now we have a
mechanism for generating these pages see
what I'm saying
but right or alternatively another
example would be there's no error
convenient idiom for deploying a gallery
view as the index page for a directory
no there isn't
that's the point what on earth is I mean
that the one thing you can do right now
yeah go ahead
that's the one thing you can do is you
can deck daughter and be yeah but it's
that going to be the default thing
reached if you go to that um that
directory yes okay does anybody look for
index dot and B or index.html or
otherwise you get a generic page okay
okay how would you put those in there I
mean do you just do them by hand or what
I mean we need only option you have
right now you have to deploy that
notebook manually but right so what we
shall do is in the file browser
presumably we should give the option to
set what the index page for a directory
is and it should display that somehow as
some badge on the directory does that
make sense make sense yeah I'm not
totally sure about the bed but what
about the UI option and I think we have
a language design proposal right role
for the analytic cloud object
index page or something could you speak
so I can hear you Joel how's that that's
now perfect yes what do you say I was
just agreeing young with young precisely
the thing that we're thinking about is
just instead of having a couple of
specific file names just that you can
set an option on a directory marking a
particular cloud object as the index for
the directory right then I'm sure we
could get more exotic from that if
there's a use case but it's pretty
straightforward extension of what we
have okay okay all right fine
but so with gallery view it sounds to me
like no it's not finished I don't
completely agree with Ricardo's function
I mean I I have a feeling it should be
another function because I think it's
got other tentacles when the thing is
dynamically picking stuff up am I making
sense I mean and which is why we didn't
say yeah right I mean maybe it should be
called gallery function view or
something or function gallery view or
something like that um or dynamic
gallery view might be might be a better
term because it's going to dynamically
generate stuff although hmm I mean I
could imagine that we would want
something where the gallery here hmm I
mean we really need to so so Bradley
that the you know this really should be
merged with the way that we're building
you know repository shingle pages don't
you think hmm I'm not sure what you mean
well I mean that we should use this
function instead of having hand created
you know index pages there should be a
way of using gallery view it's something
one often wants to do given a collection
of you know directories
you know there's the this idea of having
some kind of index of these things a
gallery of these things is a pretty
common thing you should function that
just does it I've kicked around with a
concept of having kind of a language
representation for a deployable site
like a repository where one of the pages
you know kind of like the shingles where
you give the template instead of a file
and there would be a date aspect so it
would generate new pages as new data
comes in if necessary kind of like a
repository without the Wolfram language
back-end just a web element I think it
would be there would be more than just a
gallery view I think it gets into let's
okay that gets into the web page
construction stuff which was to policing
finish all right well okay so then what
this needs to do is spin off a separate
meeting specifically about webpage
construction and gallery view
constructions okay can somebody make
that happen please thank you and Eric
and man you are here okay let's go back
to secured authentication key okay so
can somebody explain the relationship so
there is a claim from one that these
should be made left experimental I do
not understand the claim the logic does
not make sense there but what I want to
know is as we build the oauth2
authentication mechanism does generate
secure authentication key still make
sense and work yeah it should and I
think that's what why it should be
experimental as there's gonna have to be
changes as ooofff to stuff comes in and
what trying to make is ready to be it'll
have different field names for example I
don't if we go down the route of adding
things like privileges for different
we've touched on that idea but I haven't
fully developed it that would have to be
included
as well well I don't understand do we
think that there's something wrong with
what's already here let me pull out the
dock page I'm surprised that I don't
think what's here would would
necessarily become wrong but we'd
probably have to add a good bit and
maybe you know okay
I'm worried that as we add those
elements we might want to make some
minor changes to what's here all right
um what is our time scale for getting
the full version of this with oauth2
finished don't current well or - for
what we're supposed to be done by this
week so Eric can you speak to that
please well it's supposed to be done on
dev this week okay not in production so
it's I'm still reviewing the code I mean
it's it's a massive application so it's
it's not I've been trying to get to it
but I'm also dealing with getting the
WolframAlpha notebook and pro bundles
together right now so it's doing
splitting my time between the two but
I'm hoping to get things on dev this
week okay okay but so given the night of
with that I would have to work with
Bradley's team and and want to see in
the open you know yeah I know you're
trying to get these things deployed how
can they be deployed without some
language hook I mean it's using the
standard OAuth 2 protocol right so we
can
I mean generate secured authentication
key was specifically talking to the auth
- well not auth to our servers so I mean
we just need to give I just need to give
one the endpoints and everything like
that and then they can hook it up so
would generate security authentication D
then generate an oauth2 key I don't know
with one key we need to finish getting
the OAuth 2 secure authentication key
support in place before it could do that
but I mean we wouldn't want to switch
over from one to the other would we I
mean aren't there plenty of
services that still want f1o it'll have
to support both yeah we need to add the
do to support to what it is already
there there okay all right look I mean
so there's two two phase so we can do
that we can generate the oauth2 keys but
then all of our applications iCloud and
alpha would have to also implement we
don't need to do that immediately
they're perfectly happy with OAuth one
right now mm-hmm
so I mean the issue for OAuth 2 is the
many external applications like all the
single sign-on stuff and so on which
requires are worth to correct right but
that doesn't involve it's specifically
generate secure authentication key but
it does require security authentication
key itself because generate secure death
indication key is specifically for our
servers I believe fair enough so this is
where we have the old tight
yeah version is in there just one
support it
okay so then then this would be origin 2
and then it has all of the complexity
here yeah okay fine so hopefully we'll
we will see that pretty soon I mean that
should not be a difficult thing if I'm
understanding correctly for you to add
to secure the medication key is what it
needs for us - yeah it's not extremely
complicated there's a lot of design
complications because the difference you
know secure that's an occasion key you
know if we implement our server to spec
then it would be easy to make something
that works to spec but a lot of services
don't implement 100% to spec so we're
adding little ways to expand and ok so
I'm using one good doc it is single
sign-on right that would be on the on
the server side not the in language side
those what happens separate okay those
can happen separately yeah what about if
somebody has a cloud object that they
want to secure with a single sign-on
[Music]
in other words somebody at some
organization talk with a single sign-on
mechanism and people you know use that
single sign-on and somebody wants them
to be able to access a cloud object if
they're signed in with the single
sign-on mechanism there's something that
won't happen right away no but I'm
trying to understand both together so
basically the organization so when we
hook up single sign-on we register an
organization with our system so we could
pass that organization identifier to the
cloud in order to put into the
permission structure but we would need
to expose that ok so let me understand
that so that means in the cloud there
will be a thing that says secure of that
the the the permissions who can get
something the you know permissions are
who and what so the who would be secure
authentication key blah blah blah for
the single sign-on of organization X
gets to read this cloud notebook is that
correct I think something like that yeah
that would be a good mechanism don't you
think there fill the corresponding cloud
user I mean there must be read there is
yes there is a Wolfram idea associated
with it but it would for single sign-on
a lot of times it is going to be some
dummy user that's well or more to the
point
less less hacker Lee it's a generic ID
for that organization right that's what
we need to have no I don't think so
because then that means everybody who is
using that single sign-on would share
the files which we don't want right
every person you know what goes it goes
a step further than that once we start
talking about secure authentication keys
because then it's not just who and what
because the OAuth credentials typically
represent like an application through
which you are accessing so it's it's who
and how access is what so there's like
another another dimension so that's
that's another piece of who because the
the key itself should not like have the
permissions of the owner
it doesn't identify the owner it kind of
has its own set of access
so that'll be that'll be something I
think Eric and I will probably need to
sit down probably with some cloud folks
to make sure that makes sense especially
when it comes to this sign single
sign-on aspect okay all right I think
that's it for that section clearly okay
so I'm going to expect that within a few
weeks we will be talking about more
design around both - and so on is that a
fair expectation yeah I think we can do
that I can record that make sure it's in
the cloud dev meeting and that's some so
that we track what's going on unless you
think there's a different meteor for it
I think that's that's good for some
aspect of it but there's another aspect
that maybe we can and just have a
separate design review with you for the
oauth2 aspects okay I mean what happened
- we you know the series of
authentication meetings was basically
closed down I suspect those need to be
opened up again particularly as we're
starting to look at things like this
lattice you know permissions lattice and
all those kind of stuff uh probably
individual meetings for those aspects
rather than a consolidated meeting
because that ended up pulling in a bunch
of people that weren't relevant each
okay okay well certainly we can we can
make sure that these topics keep coming
up all right to cloud dev meeting please
make sure it's an item on there okay so
it's tracked okay the cloud expression
disaster by the way focus involving just
the authentication stuff can leave um
there's nothing to say about this I mean
Dorian is trying to fix this right
Dorian
yes exactly I'm currently working on a
prototype iterating with the the cloud
team as well as the Warrens team and we
are working on making a new
implementation that would suit our needs
and so what is the basis of that
implementation currently it's it's based
on the Postgres
which is a very flexible database and I
know yeah you know it okay and so that's
what question um for the this does or
does not use the readwrite database
capabilities is it using the new
readwrite no because everything is
currently so everything is done with our
two kernel so it's pure Java
implementation and and sequel and and
also it makes use of wxf and okay so
it's optimized for storing expressions
and that's fine yes you need to make
sure that whatever you're doing will
work with private clouds and so on right
so we don't have some weird Postgres
management system somewhere in the
middle of this right well you you will
need yes but I think that so that's
something that we will yes
pay attention to but yes okay okay
what's the time scale for seeing
something here so for my proof of
concept implementation I depend it's not
my main project but I'm still able to
work on it significantly and so I'm
expecting to get something within
probably weeks maybe
I know if you need to get involved
because not until it something works it
exactly but also the the design of the
of the symbols are it's going to be
probably maintained for 95% of it
because we have a good design and and so
as much as we can we need excellent
keeping and so well the idea is that we
drop only the things that makes
everything much much more complex or
which won't scale at all when in the end
is not much so let me make one comment
about this that clearly has to be a
management in
face for users so they don't wind out
discovering they have 100 gigabytes of
crud and cloud expressions and they
didn't know it right
so in a previous model here cloud
expressions were cloud objects and so
you could look at you know you could
basically just go to your file browser
and see what was there what is the plan
now so close objects also have this size
so that's one way to might on Tim you
know I understand that but is this
proxied through cloud objects or is this
some thing that is roar cloud expression
does cloud as much and have an
Associated cloud object yes so close
portion is there is a hook so there is a
cloud object that exists and and that's
okay so finally object will pretend that
it is you know will in develop the
Postgres and will pretend it has the
size of the Postgres database is that
correct that's the idea that's how it
works currently and that's something we
we keep okay that sounds sensible to me
and then presumably delete cloud
expression is unnecessary to just delete
object for the cloud object right okay
yeah yes but I mean since we have create
I mean yeah we can use delete file or
delete the fluid object yes but I mean I
don't know if if you don't think it's
necessary you I think I think we're
trying to get away from the specific
type of deletes yes there's a compelling
reason just as we probably should have a
create object that takes different types
of objects to create that probably
should be looked at in connection with
the the the data structure mechanism
Tom's new data structure mechanism maybe
you should look at that in an LCC
meeting the possibility of a pure create
object boy will look like an
object-oriented language one day okay
there okay all right that's it for cloud
a cloud expression I think let's go on
to source link um
okay now my main concern about
sourcelink is that it hasn't been as
much used as one might like um fact I'm
just writing a thing about notebook
publishing where I'm going to talk about
sourcelink
but when okay so let me walk through
when source linkers is being used by
default um I mean I I'm not completely
convinced by this and I I'm not inclined
to do experimental eyes it until we
understand a little better because I
mean when you deploy when you cloud
publish something okay okay if I take
like a gift for something and I and I
publish it on the web as something which
can be embedded elsewhere do I get
prompted to generate a source link there
or how does that work no I think the
only way it's that automatically if you
publish from the cloud in the first
place but if you start from desktop then
there is no source to point to and it
might want to continue to say you might
want to deploy this to provide a source
potentially I would think it's a bit
aggressive but that's what would need to
happen yeah right
and even then in the cloud it's not
happening for all deployment assume for
for well what is the mapping no I think
you said it but it's not like we show it
anyplace right okay so you know what
guys I don't think this is ready for
primetime but I think we should
investigate what's actually happening
here so if I do this and then I want
nerf
okay then I go here and I say publish
sell by the way why doesn't that say dot
dot dot
that should say dot dot dot right in the
menu yeah
okay now what is this Mary oh yeah yeah
so why hasn't this been fixed there's a
project for you exit oh no no no no it's
it's just that we've been working on
some of the other projects and we've had
it there in our list okay do you have a
design for it yeah we're gonna use
basically the exact same thing as the
other published dialog just change some
wording okay how about we actually get
this done how about this shows up on the
cloud Deb meeting you explain to me when
it's done okay yeah and it's been there
it's been there on the active list or on
some crazy backlog uh near the top of
one of the backlogs actually I have
noticed it there okay you know what how
about we actually get it done it doesn't
look very hard to me looks like we're
installing a dialog we already have yeah
yeah it's it's near that yeah we revisit
this this this week and okay well anyway
so what is the mechanism for sourcelink
in that dialog do you understand my
question
I'd have to check that dialogue because
it is outdated so I don't actually know
well the mechanism in the language and
in the publish menu and in the dialog
that will be appearing once we fix it it
does set the source link to this
notebook okay even if the notebook is
not is is not public correct own does
give a warning that says it isn't public
no there's no running here but then in
the actual deployed view we have sets of
rules that we spent a bunch of time on
to determine whether or not we show the
actual link so if so the source link
will be set you know in the code but we
might not display anything and deployed
view if you don't have access to the
actual source in a book right okay you
know what we're gonna need to go through
this again because you know as we look
at these embeddings like okay how does
it flow through your JavaScript
embedding yarn
just source like stuff um I'd have to
look I have to check whether it actually
happens but I guess we could show it in
the in the footer yeah I mean if we have
a source think we probably should show
it and similarly these other embeddings
you know the ones that are coming up
soon right so the embedded view does
have a footer though sometimes right but
I mean we need a design yeah okay so
listen this needs to be done properly
right it needs a design for whatever I
for iframe embedding it shows up this
the same way it does in regular deployed
view - preparing to correctly for the
JavaScript and better on the Oh in bed
embedding and all those kinds of things
right and and also hmm yeah I mean I
really want to start seeing people using
it have we have we seen a lot of people
using this or not well it is set for a
lot of notebooks okay
billions of them yeah you get it set
because there's a default behavior I
stink yeah I don't think we have stats
on like who follows the sources okay we
should probably know how often that's
done you know what I think this needs a
separate review right we should review
the design I mean graphic design and
functional design of this thing in all
these different cases by the way I mean
Colin our live stream is asking about
bibliography management um we have had a
project to do a bunch of stuff with that
and I have not heard about it in several
months and I wonder what's happening
with it and maybe somebody could could
track that down that's an Allen michael
project shared out anybody in this
meeting knows the status of it the that
is interesting I was gonna mention on
this the only thing about the language
that I have a question about that just
came up in the past couple days
is can you set a source link to an
object that you are not the owner of
essentially sighting like oh my
inspiration is from yeah I understand
that's nice yeah but then yeah then if
you're using it like that then it's more
bibliography length than a source yeah
right
and Carl also points out things about
attribution and licensing for data and
all those kinds of things yeah I mean I
think right now a source link is very
much not I mean what we could imagine is
that source link is an association that
contains a whole bunch of stuff right
and that's probably where we should go
and it should probably merge with the
bibliographic citation stuff that we're
looking at does that make sense
um I mean arguably okay so listen let us
get a custom meeting about this the
issue is standardized attribution
standardized licensing linking to other
people's content and the connection to
the bibliographic citation stuff fair
yes yep okay good and we're not going to
do experimental eyes it right now
Stephen can you switch to session
history we already have the people there
and I can eyes absolutely should be the
experimental eyes I would say the sort
of counter-argument to that is that we
haven't documented what it evaluates to
which is recognized object humph
what do you mean evaluates to I mean so
so it is well if you hit shift enter the
value has to evaluate to something and
that what it evaluates to is a I can
eyes table J okay and then what does
that do well that's the thing that
formats as deionised form and then if
you copy paste it it upon input
we'll act like the underlying expression
correct correct but if you reference
percent it'll be the head will be
ionized object I see
and has that bitten us I don't think it
has I mean I think people use this
primarily as an input mechanism not
something else
right I understand the question but well
I'm asking are people confused by this
icon eyes object return value um a
little bit but okay I'm rolling my eyes
here obviously we have to think more
about this before we just do
experimental eyes it Oh sigh okay I mean
we also are trying to understand the the
possibility of automatic code folding
automatic collision which presumably
ionize has a part of what else can we do
I mean I don't understand the fact that
it returns something other than itself
is for what reason well how else do you
expected to form it
I guess that's I guess that's right
unless it validates itself and then
formats I guess that's right mm-hmm but
when you say people have sometimes been
confused can you can you characterize
that well there was a stack exchange
thread of people who were confused yes
okay can we understand the confusion I
mean can we can we discuss the confusion
I mean so if I say % % % well then it
always and I get that now what happens
if I say if I take if I copy this and I
paste it well if I evaluate this I'm
gonna get OH
well that's very fine how did that work
well the its it has an interpretation
which is the the input to icon eyes okay
so wait a minute wait a minute let me
wait why I'm bizarrely there are no
input and output lines in the snow book
how could that be why is that Rory I
switched it off I mean I turned it off
and II normal preferences so just copied
in a new notebook okay
[Music]
by the way random question all the the
publish magnify etcetera options are
those in 1.53 or not that's a cloud
question they are not oh gosh kind of
annoying kind of messes up something I
wanted to explain in this notebook
publishing post that I had been assigned
to write okay
that's a shame okay so here here we've
got this okay so now if I say percent
squared I'm gonna get garbage and what
mechanism do I have to get rid of that
I mean copy it and use it as an input
okay so if I take this and I use it as
an input then I get that now can I also
use defer or whatever can can I take
that does that work and say is that the
right write function
[Music]
no that's definitely not the right
function um but there should be some
programmatic way to take something that
has been I can eyes so imagine you had a
button for example you were trying to do
this you need some way to get it to D I
can eyes as purely as a piece of code am
I making sense okay you need a way some
function that you can apply two percent
eighty here to D icon eyes those things
what is that function okay we don't know
the answer but we need to figure out the
answer okay okay so Karl is asking on
our live stream about having ionised
object would also allow out of course
storage yeah that's an interesting point
I don't know what we've done on that yet
I mean things like data set we now have
a mechanism just like with audio and so
on that says store in the notebook or
don't store in the notebook right before
I can Iser don't believe we're doing
that right now could we hey it's
possible oh okay you don't seem to be
awake so I'm not gonna I'm not going to
continue this given that no here all
right but we need to separately pick
that up think about it okay and here
think we're out of time here for this
meeting it's a pity that got scheduled
when it did but we will continue it a
different time alright thanks everybody
see you later bye